kind of low on cash right now do you
think I could get in advance on the
universal basic income there's like two
or three thousand dollars you can just
give me now we have to make this happen
for everyone could you just give me the
money in in your wallet a couple bucks
right now it'd be great
I just love that clip we watched it like
10 times it looks like it's right out of
the office doesn't it like that Yang
comes off as Michael Scott right there
it's just so absolutely perfect
anywho I'm Dave Rubin this is the Reuben
report it's June 7th in the year 2023
we're live streaming on Rumble YouTube
and locals we've got a post game show
where you can communicate directly with
me share your thoughts opinions your
crazy rants whatever you want at
reubenreport.locals.com uh and today is
a big day people there is something a
brewing in the air related to all of the
things that we talk about uh because we
just heard about a half hour ago that
the head of CNN the new head who
replaced the old head uh Chris Licht
he's out at CNN already there is a
massive shift in corporate press
mainstream media whatever you want to
call it and then on top of that
yesterday if you have not seen it last
night out of nowhere Tucker Carlson
returned that's right he debuted his new
show on Twitter so there is a I think
this is
a cataclysmic shift in the media
landscape right now and this fits sort
of everything I've been talking about
about building new things about telling
the truth around getting about getting
around The Gatekeepers
etc etc and of course uh how the media
reacts to those of us who dare tell the
truth and do actual reporting and try to
give roughly honest opinions and the
point ladies and gentlemen is that we
can fight it we are fighting it good
things are happening so that is the
theme for today's program and before we
get to it let me talk to you about
moinkbox I know that you guys know that
60 of U.S pork production comes from one
company owned by the Chinese and their
Hogs are given something called
ractopamine which is banned in 160
countries including China yet you find
it in your grocery aisle every day well
guys there's a better way I want to tell
you about moink that is Moo plus oink
Mike delivers grass-fed and grass-finish
beef and lamb pastured pork and chicken
sustainable wild caught Alaskan salmon
and more straight to your door you
choose the meat delivered in every box
like Ribeyes chicken breast pork chops
salmon fillets and more plus he can
cancel anytime there's nothing better
than cooking my Meats on my big green
egg on a Friday evening Shark Tank host
Kevin O'Leary called moink's bacon the
best bacon he's ever tasted and they
guarantee you'll say oink oink I'm just
so happy I got boys keep American
farming going by signing up at
workbox.com Reuben right now and
listeners of this show get free filet
mignon at every order for a year that's
one of the best filet mignon you'll ever
taste but only for a limited time that's
m-o-i-n-k box.com reuben moinkbox.com
reuben and now back to me all right
let's get right to it last night out of
nowhere there was no advanced warning I
didn't know about it nobody that I knew
or knows knew about it Tucker tweeted
this
so that was the link to the direct video
which was embedded into Twitter all he
said was episode one uh as you can see
where uh this was about an hour I think
we took this screenshot about an hour
after he posted it it was already up to
61.7 million views now interestingly I
think it's worth noting it's a little
unclear to me how Twitter is exactly
counting views you know is a view he put
up well how long was the show it's about
20 20 minutes or so right what's that 10
minutes so he put up a 10 minute video
so when they're counting views and this
is elon's gonna have to explain this a
little bit more to the people I think
you know what counts as a view is it a
view like someone just scrolled past it
in their feed they saw it for a split
second is that a view or is it a view if
someone actually watches 30 seconds in
etc etc this has been something that
advertisers and tech companies Facebook
Instagram Twitter Etc have been trying
to figure out forever like what is a
legitimate view you watching this right
now if you've been with me for the first
two minutes here like that's obviously a
view that should be counted if you
literally clicked on this video for one
second we're like
clicked away is that really a view like
what's the value in that but putting
that aside for a moment obviously there
was great Fanfare attached to this thing
and I thought we'd show you just
Tucker's first 30 seconds the first 30
seconds of his return because he did it
with very few Frills or anything else he
just kind of went right to it
hey it's Tucker Carlson this morning it
looks like somebody blew up that kakovka
Dam in southern Ukraine the rushing wall
of water wiped out entire Villages
destroyed a critical hydropower plant
and as of tonight puts the largest
nuclear reactor in Europe in danger of
melting down so if this was intentional
it was not a military tactic it was an
act of terrorism the question is who did
it
as I said No Frills no fancy Graphics uh
somewhat demure set I would say which he
obviously just well I can't say
obviously I assume he just funded
himself and put together it's probably
in his house but did not do much up top
just got right to the news now what's
interesting about this issue with the
dam in Ukraine and the water on its way
uh to the nuclear reactor is uh someone
could check me on this was that on CNN
yesterday was that on MSNBC yesterday
was that even on Fox yesterday I don't
know I actually don't know the answer I
am glad to see Tucker doing a show from
home with the kind of calm set no crazy
Graphics it reminds me of another show
that you might be watching right now
very exciting it's like things are
actually kind of going in the direction
that a bunch of us have sort of
predicted uh at the end of the uh the
Tucker show he did then talk a little
bit more broadly about why he is doing
this show why he's using Twitter to get
word out there and a bit more take a
look
but mostly they just ignore the stories
that matter
what's happened to the hundreds of
billions of U.S dollars we've sent to
Ukraine no clue
who organized those BLM riots three
years ago no one's gotten to the bottom
of that what exactly happened on 9 11
well it's still classified how did
Jeffrey Epstein make all that money how
did he die how about JFK and so
endlessly on
not only are the media not interested in
any of this they are actively hostile to
anybody who is in journalism curiosity
is the gravest crime secrecy is a
powerful tool of control
stop asking how we got so rich here's
another story about racism go eat each
other
that's the program that's how most of us
now live here in the United States
manipulated by lies silenced by taboos
it is unhealthy and is dehumanizing and
we're tired of it you know it's so
interesting because if you remember when
Tucker got fired or whatever you want to
call it from Fox there were so many
people in mainstream media and mostly
Democrat Democrat politicians AOC et
cetera that were cheering it on they
were so excited and it was just so
obvious I even tweeted to AOC like uh
you do realize this is going to make him
stronger than ever just like patience
lady and look whether you agree with
Tucker on everything whether you want to
find out more about what may or may not
have happened to JFK or hear about 9 11
conspiracy theories or any of the issues
that he just mentioned there it is very
clear that the guy's voice should be
heard he should have the ability to
cover the issues that he wants to cover
to talk about the things that he thinks
are important I think it's interesting
and probably uh not nothing that he
started the show with the Ukraine thing
because I I just suspect I truly don't
know this but you know a lot of people
were theorizing that the reason that fox
got rid of him had to do with the
lawsuit uh you know the Dominion lawsuit
that fox lost they had to pay about 800
million dollars related to election
fraud and all that a lot of people were
saying that was the thing that got they
got rid of him for my suspicion is it
has a bit more to do with some of what
he was doing the digging related to what
really is going on in Ukraine
regardless of whether I'm right or wrong
it's actually irrelevant the point is
the guy is back the guy is back we'll
see where else you know he obviously is
still under contract with Fox which
probably leads you to see why he's on
Twitter and not some other places
because Twitter they probably have some
restrictions around him like I don't
know but that would be the the general
way you know obviously when you sign
these contracts if you're on Fox they
say you can't be on CNN or you can't be
on this video site or something else
maybe he owned his own Twitter account
we'll find out more about all of that
kind of stuff but it is good that he is
back again whether you agree with him on
everything or not I think he will we'll
see if this is going to be a Daily Show
like how he's going to expand it etc etc
anyway it is directly related to
something that just happened in the last
40 minutes or so uh CNN chairman the new
guy the CEO Chris Licht who just how
long ago the guy's been in had this war
at six months was it a year even I don't
even know if it's a year we can check on
that uh took over uh from Jeff Zucker
who really wrecked CNN had a couple
years of just horribleness at CNN and
then Chris Licht came in said we're not
going to be his partisan they couldn't
stop themselves they're as partisan and
hacky as ever and now as of uh the last
hour he is out at CNN and they announced
that on CNN
we have news now to report involving our
own network news to us here at CNN and
you at home CNN's chairman and CEO Chris
Licht is leaving the network Licht took
over the network a little over a year
ago David zazlov the chairman of CNN's
parent company Warner Brothers Discovery
he just made the announcement at the
network editorial meeting for now a
leadership team will take click's place
led by Amy and tell us who's the
Executive Vice President of talent and
content development along with Virginia
Mosley the EVP of editorial Eric
shirling our programming EVP and David
Levy our new Chief Operating Officer all
right so we will find out more about
this and I think it's just a sign of the
times right people are tuning out of
mainstream media and they damn well
deserve it they are finding new Outlets
whether it's this whether it's Tucker
whatever it might be regardless of your
political affiliation and I think Licht
probably got there and was like I want
this thing to be less partisan but what
wokism has so infected the thing that
even if you get rid of Chris Cuomo and
even if you get rid of Don Lemon and you
clear house it's so infected in the
system that you cannot fix something
like that I also think it's interesting
this all happens to the backdrop of
MSNBC or NBC getting rid of Chuck Todd
from Meet the Press like there is a
wholesale a change uh happening right
now and I'm telling you guys it's really
good there's something funny about CNN
reporting on the head of CNN leaving
that would be like me doing the show one
day and being like I have to report to
everybody that the head of the Reuben
report Dave Rubin will no longer be
hosting the Reuben report Clyde the dog
will be taking over his duties uh Justin
the son will be working the cameras and
it's just it's so sick ridiculous anyway
let's link this to something else that's
going on here because we really are in a
technological Revolution right now and I
know sometimes it's really scary and the
algorithms are annoying and this
freaking thing in our pockets driving us
all crazy and everything else but
there's good things related to it and
bad things right like we've all started
communicating through these pipes right
like there's we can complain about
social media all day but like even if
you just look at the 20 years the
internet it freed us from the the like
really uh I would say overreaching
way that the corporate media was
controlling us we didn't know what we
didn't know right it was Plato's Cave we
didn't know what was outside of the cave
basically but there are new technologies
coming whether we like it or not and we
better start thinking about our
relationship with them you know the
thing is when we all got the phone and
we you know we got on Facebook we got on
all these things we didn't know that we
were the product we didn't know what we
were getting in on that they were going
to sell our data and track US and all
these things but now we know some of
that so when new products come down the
pike we should we should view them with
a little skepticism so if you did not
see this two days ago Apple CEO Tim Cook
unveiled Apple's new 3 500 that's right
3 500 Vision Pro product this is sort of
VR augmented reality and more we're
going to show you about a minute and a
half of the launch because I think this
is also directly related to the Meltdown
of mainstream media how uh Tech is
overtaking Corporate press etc etc to
take a look at this
excited to announce an entirely new AR
platform with a revolutionary new
product and here it is
foreign
[Music]
Vision Pro is a new kind of computer
that augments Reality by seamlessly
blending the real world with the digital
world
Vision Pro feels familiar yet it's
entirely new
you can see hear and interact with
digital content just like it's in your
physical space
and you control Vision Pro using the
most natural and intuitive tools your
eyes hands and voice
with Vision Pro you're no longer limited
by a display use your apps anywhere and
make them any size you want
capture photos and videos and relive
your most important memories in an
entirely new way
guys did you see Ready Player One some
of you maybe read the book Ready Player
one or did you see the movie The
Spielberg movie from a couple years ago
I mean it is happening right now I'm not
telling you that thing is inherently
evil I'm not telling you Tim Cook or
apple are inherently evil I'm not
telling you that I'll never try that
freaking thing I don't think I'm gonna
buy it but I'm not telling you I'm never
gonna put on the glasses and be like wow
this is kind of cool for a moment and
everything else but we we now have a
brief moment where you can feel them why
is it that Facebook changed the parent
company's name to meta and then started
trying to push everybody into the
metaverse right once they get you in
this thing that you wear in front of
your uh eyes and then you have augmented
reality that's what they call it a a AR
so augmented reality meaning you're
seeing a screen and you're seeing
reality together and it's like okay fine
you can play video games on it you can
do these things with your kids you could
do all this stuff and again I'm not
saying it's all just evil in and of
itself but we have to know that that's
the direction that that a certain part
of humanity is going not everyone's
going to go in that direction but but a
huge amount of people are and there's
going to be a massive push to put us in
that world I said to the guys as that
thing was mine it's like I'm pretty sure
people are only going to use that for
porn I'm not even sure how they're going
to use it for porn but it just strikes
me as like that's really where this is
going to go which by the way you know
porn ends up pushing Technologies
there's the famous story uh late 70s
they covered this a little bit in the
movie Boogie Nights if you never saw
that it's such an absolutely spectacular
movie but when there was VHS and betamax
we're going to be the two ways that
people would be watching you know film
at home basically and VHS decide the
porn people basically went with VHS and
that killed betamax anyway that's a
total sidebar but anyway the point is we
are ending we are entering this weird
dystopian future related to technology
and it's somehow connected to the
Meltdown of the media and all of these
things like again I always tell you I'm
I'm always trying to put together a
puzzle I'm not sure what the puzzle
looks like exactly and that makes it
complex but I think it's worth watching
here's just a little bit more 20 seconds
more uh and and it's it's also like
bizarrely creepy and like why wouldn't
you live in reality how about that
and pro is Apple's first ever 3D camera
now you can capture photos and videos
with remarkable depth and relive a
memory as if you're right back in the
exact moment
you could do that of course you could
also sit with your kids and not have to
film everything now of course we do that
I have two young Sons we're taking a lot
of pictures and videos I try not to have
my phone around with them often but like
this this Obsession like I will sit
there my kids will be playing I'll be
recording it the whole time years from
now someone could be recording me
recording it and someone will be
recording him recording that it really
is kind of nutty and all I'm saying is
let's let's be somewhat careful as we as
we go down this road uh because the
road's being laid out and a whole bunch
of us are going to go down on it by the
way this thing uh where the guy is like
watching his the kids you know the stuff
from the past with the kids that's also
a moment from a Minority Report if you
want to check out another fantastic
that's actually a Spielberg movie too if
you want to see a great sci-fi dystopian
type future it doesn't usually work out
that well in these dystopian movies
that's one of the things but the reason
I say we have to be wary about what road
we're going to go down down as all of
this shifts right as CNN collapses as
the tech companies rise as they try to
put
literally gear on your body and then
eventually they'll want to chop your arm
off and give you a robot arm and you
know it's not just your genitals they're
trying to chop off like all of this
weird transhumanist stuff and all this
stuff we have to be wary because what
have these companies been doing do they
do they have the track record that makes
you want to follow them into the new
Digital Universe you know do you want to
follow Mark Zuckerberg and meta and
Facebook do you think that he's such a
great guy and that he's been fair with
what he's done with your data and what
he's done with his money that he's made
off you relative to elections and much
more and of course it's not just Mark
Zuckerberg here's a headline from
Gizmodo as far as what Apple's been up
to
Apple fined 8.5 million which is
obviously nothing for apple apple fined
8.5 million for illegally collecting
iPhone users data for ads so it's like
all right all right you guys are going
to give us the stuff that we're going to
put on our face we're going to video our
kids we're gonna live in this digital
world you're going to take our data
occasionally you'll pay fines again guys
I'm just
just kind of waving a little something
like let's just
be aware of what's going on here
interestingly related to all of that
there are some pockets of America where
some public people are trying to take
some precautions related to all of this
uh We've shown you some video over the
last couple of months that Governor
DeSantis has been talking about creating
a digital Bill of Rights to make sure
that your data is yours that these
companies basically can't use and abuse
you and he actually just signed that
digital Bill of Rights in Florida
yesterday
it basically establishes a number of
protections for Floridians with respect
to the digital sphere one the right to
control your personal data including the
right to confirm access and delete your
personal data from a social platform you
should be in control of this and
ultimately have the final say over it
also has the right to know that your
personal data will not be used against
you when purchasing a home obtaining
health insurance or being hired that's
important for for privacy you also have
the right to opt out of having your
personal data sold so you should have
the right to say no you know I don't
want you selling my data you now will
with this book with this bill and then
finally this provides the right to
protect children from personal data
collection do you really want companies
mining your your child's data now you're
going to have protection against it all
right so that's that's a beautiful thing
there will be pockets in America it will
mostly be red states starting with
Florida and then that Blu print that
gets exported to a couple other states I
suspect that Tennessee and Texas and a
bunch of other states will start doing a
similar thing and people who live within
the laws of these states will be able to
protect their data have opt-in or app to
opt opt out choices they'll be
protecting their kids more on on many
fronts not just the digital sphere as
you know and I think that is pretty
solid now let's connect that to
something else because as I said CNN is
in the middle of a meltdown the CEO is
stepping down we can feel this
technological shift happening from you
know corporate press on television to
online media now you know metaverse kind
of stuff but what the corporate press
and whoever it is the people that want
to control you more than anything else
what they hate are the people that are
doing anything to free you to uh to
making sure and guaranteeing that your
rights are protected and that you can
live as you see fit so I saw this on CNN
yesterday well I don't have a television
with cable but I saw a clip of it on the
computer over there that CNN is going
after uh Ron DeSantis of course and why
are they going after him well I think we
just laid out a good case for right he's
fighting against the woke he's fighting
for a digital Bill of Rights you know
all the reasons check out this
ridiculously slanted piece that they did
about Ron DeSantis and Clarence Thomas
and wonder why this Chris Licht is
stepping down today
also this morning new details about the
close relationship between Republican
presidential candidate Ron DeSantis and
Supreme Court Justice Clarence Thomas it
has to do with one connection really
Leonard Leo a conservative activist who
had previously advised both the Santos
and Donald Trump on judicial nominations
Leo is also friends with Justice Thomas
so three years ago at an event for the
Florida chapter of the Federalist
Society DeSantis said this about Justice
Thomas
this is a Justice that has the courage
of his convictions and he's willing to
apply the Constitution you know
regardless of any criticism that he may
face because I do think he is our
greatest living Justice thank you
[Applause]
scientist Thomas and Leo all went out to
dinner
guys
Ron DeSantis eats dinner
with a black guy
who happens to be a pretty cool black
guy do you realize how insane this is
the hypocrisy of these people is so
ridiculous they thought they just had
some sort of bombshell that Ron DeSantis
the governor of Florida trying to become
the president of the United States went
to an event said nice things about
Clarence Thomas who's a Supreme Court
Justice they happen to agree you know
basically on the issues on how the
Constitution uh should be treated and
how you know we should live by the laws
of the land and that sort of thing they
take video the video is public it's not
like he privately said something about
Clarence Thomas and then it was leaked
it was like but they make up this
nonsense and then the NPCs the
non-playable characters who watch CNN
they then have dinner with people and
they go my god did you see that
bombshell report on CNN do you know that
Ron DeSantis with some other guy had
dinner with Clarence Thomas and then
somebody goes my God I better tell
somebody about that it's so absolutely
insane but they cannot stop themselves
so now watch this it's another one from
CNN because because the thing that was
happening yesterday it's leaking into a
bit of today is that Ron DeSantis once
again is getting illegal immigrants out
of Florida and he's sending them to
California now in Florida we abide by
the laws now of course Ron DeSantis is
not president yet uh so the president is
the one who is supposed to protect the
borders obviously Joe Biden and the
Democrats aren't going to do that so you
end up leaving it to the states right
Texas Arizona border states now have to
do the job that the federal government
will not do and even some Democrats are
waking up to that we're going to show
you some video of RFK who was at the
Border in Arizona in just a moment in
any event uh Florida is now sending more
illegal immigrants these are not legal
immigrants to the United States we're
sending them to Cali Cali and Gavin
Newsom you know we're a sanctuary State
we're a sanctuary City we love everybody
nobody's illegal diversity inclusion
blah blah blah Florida's saying hey we
don't do that so can you take these
people for us that's what's happening
right now watch the way uh CNN's
Democrat activist Jake Tapper and
California attorney general Rob Banta
framed this issue
the argument from the likes of Governor
Abbott or Governor DeSantis is that it's
unfair that Biden's weak border policies
this is their terminology not mine uh
results in so many Asylum Seekers going
to Florida and they want other states uh
to have to share the burden uh what
would your response to that be
the place time and and manner for
discussing important policy issues like
this it can be happened through Congress
uh through the Democratic process and
elections uh they we have a president
and a United States in a Congress that
has certain policies in place one of
them is our Asylum seeking process it
has been pursued and has been pursued
lawfully uh to our understanding by all
36 of these individuals who have
hearings to seek Asylum here in the
United States of America and it's not
lost on me the great irony that Florida
not a border state Florida is sending
migrants from Texas to California a
border state that the state with the
most immigrants in the United States of
America a place that lives and thrives
with immigrants to do what to to to show
us how to live and Thrive with
immigrants we know how uh it's too late
for that and and so it's a political
stunt it's cheap and it's cruel and it's
on the backs of human being what an
absolute clown that guy is if California
is just thriving and doing great with
these people and it's a sanctuary State
congrats congrats man you got 36 more of
these people now they also frame it that
these people are legal Asylum Seekers so
you know if you want legal asylum in the
United States it's like oh you've got
like I don't know a gang trying to kill
you you're fleeing political persecution
you're really banged up and you would
think in the old days political
persecution try to think around World
War II it was people with you know Rags
basically and one suitcase if anything
and they were fleeing bombs and War and
a whole bunch more so what did Future
president DeSantis do that was so bad
well we've got some video of these
people you tell me if these people these
are the 36 people that they're referring
to uh in this video that you just saw
the Attorney General from California and
Jake Tapper you tell me do these people
seem like they're really fleeing the
worst of the worst I gotta get the
sunglasses that this guy has let's put
this on here we go there's some video uh
some audio to some of it so here they
are they look like perfectly you know
these are young people they're doing
just fine and oh look at this they're in
a party van yeah they're having a good
time young guys they look like could be
Americans here they are again all nice
clothes everyone's wearing clothes that
fit backpacks Smiles look at the jackets
on these people they're better dressed
than anyone look at the shades on that
dude that's right out of uh he's a
snowboarder man we made it to California
thank God very thankful to God look at
these guys where are the chicks where
are the babies where are the old women
at any point did you feel like you were
treated poorly no no they treated the
super well
[Music]
you got it guys you got it so
congratulations Gavin Newsom
congratulations attorney general
congratulations Jake Tapper and you know
what you're damn well right Florida is
not a Border Town in that we are
bordered mostly by water and then we
have borders with some uh other states
in the United States but we care about
the law
and Joe Biden will not do his job and I
don't hear I don't think anyone in
Florida is upset by this I don't think
any sane person in America is upset by
this you want this Cali it's all yours
now
let's link that to something else
happening with the Democrats right now
because this is the fault of the
Democrats even let's say you're watching
this right now and you're not in total
agreement you're like ah it feels like a
little bit of a political stunt and
maybe the sadness could be a little
nicer or something like that
okay I'll grant you that I I don't
personally agree but let's just say
that's your position right well what
you'd still have to do first is blame
whoever it was that let these people in
in the first place again do those people
seem like they are Asylum Seekers who
should immediately be allowed into the
United States right obviously not okay
you don't have to be a freaking rocket
scientist obviously not but what's
happening now is it's so out of control
it is so obvious that even a couple
Democrats as crazy as the party has gone
even a couple Democrats are realizing it
RFK Jr who's running for president as a
Democrat again I'm still not sure what
makes him a Democrat other than the name
Kennedy
he's wrong and I will ask him when we uh
when we get him on the show which is in
the works
um he went to the Border last night he
did a Twitter spaces two or three days
ago with uh with Elon Musk where and by
the way Elon has said every presidential
candidate is welcome so we'll see who
actually does it where he said we should
immediately close down the Border then
which that sounds far more like a trump
or DeSantis or republican position than
a Democrat right well then last night he
went at 2 A.M to our border in Yuma
Arizona and he posted this
hey everybody I'm at the board of wall
and around Yuma Arizona it's about two
o'clock in the morning
um we've watched about 150 people come
across you can see the end of the wall
down there
and we've watched about 150 people come
across
in the last hour the first group were
about uh 50 or 60 people from Africa
from West Africa
this group that is filing behind me
right now we interviewed many of them
uh they're from Peru Afghanistan
Uzbekistan Kazakhstan
Afghanistan Bangladesh India
China
Tibet Nepal
and all together
people have come across right here
from 117 nations in the last couple of
years
why is CNN not reporting that why is RFK
Jr having to go down to the border to do
that video and CNN will not cover that
why don't they have a guy there
reporting that all of these illegal
immigrants these Nationals these are not
people again who are fleeing some they
may not be thrilled where they are and
they really like the United States which
is also odd because the lefties are
always telling us how horrible the
United States is so it would be it's odd
that people flee to this horrific
oppression oppression oppressive
patriarchy and racist you know nazi-like
entity but
as you can see they're also not just
Mexicans right so they're from all over
the world they're coming CNN refuses to
cover it RFK is covering it elon's
letting him go on a Twitter space all
the other uh presidential candidates are
welcome to do the same but now let's go
back to because he's the outlier on the
Democrat side right so a Democrat who's
honestly looking at the issues and
saying we've got a real problem here now
let's go to more of the Gavin Newsom
style of this uh New York city mayor
Eric Adams who basically is a communist
uh is now calling and again New York is
basically a sanctuary State and New York
City is a sanctuary City meaning if you
come there they will take care of you
you will get Services you will get a
phone they will figure out housing for
you well it's not just that they want to
find public housing for you this one is
wild if you think that these people are
not Communists every now and again they
actually say the part that your own
private property will not be yours this
is absolutely wild and again was this
covered on CNN or MSNBC here is New York
city mayor Eric Adams calling on New
Yorkers to house illegal aliens in their
private residences play the videotape
is with discipline and we're executing
on it it is my vision uh to take the
next step to this to go to the faith
base the locales and then move to a
private residence of their residents who
are suffering right now because of
economic challenges they have spare
rooms they have locales and and we can
find a way to get over the 30-day Rule
and other rules that government has in
in this place we can take that 4.2
billion dollars 4.3 it may be now that
we potentially have to spend and we can
put it back in the pockets of everyday
New Yorkers everyday houses of worship
instead of putting in the pockets of
Corporations and some of those
corporations come from outside our city
these people should be studied they
should be studied by sociologists and
scientists spiritual leaders
everything they do is wrong and
backwards and you might go but he thinks
he's doing the right thing but the road
to hell is paved with good intentions
what he is saying there is for some of
these people that are supposed to be
kicked out after 30 days okay we'll try
the faith-based thing we'll set him up
in churches and synagogues and things
like that for a little bit but uh you
know we're going to keep letting them in
uh you've got a room over there how many
people you think Eric Adams is going to
have living in the mayor's residence
with him
you think any of those guys even even
the sunglass guy with those cool shades
you don't think he would maybe get in
there this is what they are going to do
do not think that they will not take
this to the craziest the nth degree of
lunacy because they will take it there
they are telling you they will take it
there your private residence why is your
private residence yours why is your
property yours you've got to help those
people my parents still live in New York
and I want to be very clear Mom and Dad
if you're watching the show today if my
childhood bedroom ever becomes a center
for illegal immigrants
uh I'm not gonna be able to visit you at
the old age home one day that's we're
just putting it out there I cannot do it
I cannot do it I've got my old posters
are still in there from like 1992 and
that's the way it's going to be anyway
it's not just New York city that is
completely out of control it's the
entire State uh Governor Kathy hokel who
was one of the worst awful human beings
on planet Earth when it came to covid uh
get this this is from Logan radick who
is an actual journalist this is from him
on Twitter she had a press conference
the other day during an appearance in
Syracuse which is Upstate New York on
Friday New York Governor Kathy hokel
urged Upstate counties to allow migrants
to be housed in their communities oh
that's right so let's just send them all
up to Syracuse let's send them up to
Binghamton where I went to college you
know the Reuben report does have one
employee I'm not going to name him who
works remote does live in Upstate New
York uh and person who's watching this
right now I just want you to then I will
do everything possible to make sure that
you do not have to house any illegal
immigrants either and you're always
welcome to move down to Florida do you
see how insane this is the mayor of New
York City we're going to put them in
private residences the the governor of
the state let's just move them up to
Syracuse let's just what if you live in
Syracuse or you live you know already
new upper New York State
Upstate New York it's already extremely
economically depressed it's one of the
most economically depressed areas in the
entire United States so now let's just
bring in a whole bunch of people a whole
bunch of people from all these different
countries they don't necessarily speak
English we have no idea what their
cultural Identity or belief systems are
we have no idea what their work uh skill
or desire to even work is and let's just
dump them into these communities that
are hurting already and see what happens
Democrat 101 but ladies and Gentlemen
let's shift a little bit because there
is some pushback against the lunacy
what's been the main lunacy lately the
main lunacy is usually related to
genitals because there's a certain set
of people that think that if you have
the genitals attached to you it doesn't
make you that sex and they've been
pushing this on everybody uh
particularly kids so get this one out of
Los Angeles right now we've got a quote
from Fox La here this is wild a protest
how held outside of Glendale this is Los
Angeles a Glendale school board meeting
over the students right to choose their
pronouns took a chaotic turn Tuesday
evening multiple groups gathered outside
the Glendale Unified School Board
building as they protested over pronouns
at one point during the protests punches
were thrown and police in Glendale had
to jump in to stop the violence
meanwhile in Los Angeles LAUSD board
Annette unanimously approved a
resolution Tuesday encouraging all
schools to incorporate lgbtq Plus Class
Concepts as part of the curriculum in
addition to formerly recognizing June AS
lgbtq Plus pride month while also
designating October as lgbtq History
Month Jesus the commotion and fights
faded shortly after the fight as crowds
were ordered to disperse in Temecula so
this is a little bit outside of Los
Angeles teachers gathered to protest
Temecula Valley Unified School District
board's decision to exclude certain
textbooks from the curriculum the
controversy in Temecula surrounds the
debate over social social studies
textbook proposed for the fourth grade
curriculum okay we're going to show you
some video in just a second of what
happened in Glendale where a bunch of
parents were basically saying uh no we
are not going to push this woke crazy
gender stuff and pronoun nonsense on our
children and they've had it with this
craziness but La so now there's two gay
months they took June and now and now
they want October too and they're making
sure that this stuff is taught in school
I have said this many times I don't have
a problem with gay people my husband is
gay all right it's not an issue but you
should why would you be teaching this in
schools how about teaching math and
history
etc etc anyway here is uh some of the
video
from the fight that broke out these are
radical trans activists with antifa
people and far left protesters duking it
out with these are mostly Armenian
Glendale is like home of the Armenian
Community uh in Los Angeles these are
mostly Armenian American uh
parents in Glendale take a look
guess what guys this is going to happen
more and more across blue cities and
blue States because for this slim set of
people that will live in these places
that are still sane I mean think about
it do you think that it doesn't matter
that these parents are Armenian or
anything else they that happens to be a
very Armenian Community I mean actually
I can't say it has nothing it doesn't
matter at all like the Armenian people
seem like they care about reality at
least in this community and that's
pretty good right
the more do you think that any of those
parents were waking up every day like
let's get out there and protest gays
guess what there are gays that live in
Glendale nobody cares nobody cares if
you keep pushing this nonsense through
the curriculum at the schools on their
children eventually parents say enough
is enough as you know this is what
caused Glenn Younkin to win in Virginia
he started backing the parents instead
of the radicals right
um so it's not as if so I don't know who
started the fight I don't know who threw
the first Punch or maybe spit on
somebody or anything else but you must
understand there's a set of people who
are radical activists who are trying to
indoctrinate others people's children
and then there's a set of parents whose
ultimate responsibility is to take care
of their children so it is fairly
obvious who the good guys are in this
situation but it continues and it is
going to continue as I said in blue
States and blue cities one of the
craziest places in America right now is
Montgomery County Maryland right outside
of DC and take a look at this this is a
bunch of immigrant parents who in
Essence legal immigrant parents who are
protesting white woke women who are
pushing woke ideology on their kids
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
it's interesting because this is so
counter to the way the left treats the
world right so on what you see there
first is a bunch of people who have
diversity of skin color I don't really
care about that but some of them are
brown and white or whatever and they
just are standing there calmly uh you
know stop chopping kids genitals off
religious freedom nobody's screaming or
anything and then you see the people on
the other side and okay they seem happy
like that's why it's confusing to so
many young people it's like oh look at
them they're cheering and they've got
colors ah imagine if you were an alien
and you just landed and you was looking
around
what would you possibly make of this
situation again only one side is trying
to push anything on the other side the
parents are the ones that are saying hey
we should have something to do with what
our children learn you can do whatever
you want in the privacy of your own home
as a Consulting adult and that's why
this is so freaking dangerous these
activists have so assaulted what was a
just gay rights movement in that every
person in the United States should have
equal rights so there's so ultimately
there's no such thing as gay rights
there would just be equal rights and
it's the t's and these radical lunatics
who are screaming with these ridiculous
Flags those flags are a political
ideology they have nothing to do with
their sexuality uh anyway Elon Musk
tweeted about what's going on here and
he said I I mean he just nailed it they
keep chanting protect our children but
the children in question are not theirs
doesn't that get to it maybe more than
anything else but they think they're
theirs they are theirs right like
Hillary Clinton it takes a village
Kamala Paris has said this many times
they're not your children they're our
children
I guarantee you m efforts my children
are my children not your children and
I'm going to do everything I can to
protect them from people like you so it
is good to see that parents are waking
up Etc et cetera this is also by the way
if you want any degree of social
cohesion it's why reality is so
important why is it that we're not going
to have these crazy riots in places like
Florida and Tennessee and Texas because
we are getting this stuff out of our
schools so parents will have more
responsibility and the radicals it's not
the radicals will not exist and every
now and again there's going to be some
weird incidences and all that but
ultimately you will you will separate uh
reality from the crazy people right and
you will make sure that oh it's not
being taught everywhere so if you want
to be a radical trans communist activist
you can be that in Florida in your own
home and you can protest on public
property but you can't force it on
everyone else's children and into all of
our public policy unfortunately the left
has gone so deep that they whether it
comes to immigration where they're just
like oh our systems are collapsing well
let's uh instead of putting more
pressure on the system let's actually
send it send these people into other
people's homes or what they do with kids
related to the schools okay you get it
you get it so the question really is who
is fighting on the public policy front
and then what do we need what do we
actually have to do from a policy
position
uh to crush this thing well it's pretty
freaking obvious right uh here are some
of the policies that Ron DeSantis has uh
signed into law over the last couple
weeks as the legislative session closed
uh this lets kid kids be kids was the
was the sort of bumper sticker name of
this and a couple things I just want to
mention here that will not be happening
in Florida anymore outlawing permanent
mutilation of minors removing pronoun
politics and expanding parental rights
in education protecting children's
innocence ensuring women's safety
expanding access to Youth Sports this is
all good stuff guys and it's not just
all good stuff it's just obvious stuff
right parental rights making sure that
girls aren't having the crap kicked out
of them by Boys in sports all of these
things we know they are right and just
and that will then lead
it then leads to happier people more
functioning people people who aren't
anxiety ridden because they're not
constantly walking around at odds with
the truth and everything else and he has
done such a nice job doing all of this
which is why the system hates him which
is why they're literally running stories
on CNN that the guy a couple of years
ago had lunch with Clarence Thomas holy
cow he had lunch with Clarence Thomas
it's incredible but he is getting
support from all Corners uh of the
country and from all types of people so
you know the story of uh Riley games
Riley Gaines is the swimmer who came in
second to Leah Thomas who is the guy who
pretends to be a girl to be swimming he
was ranked something like 478th
something like that when he was a male
swimmer became a girl swimmer broke
every freaking record beat Riley Gaines
in one of these uh swimming competitions
DeSantis actually signed something into
law that she technically was the winner
anyway Riley Gaines who's become an
incredible activist now she is an
activist fighting for women which is
what the feminist movement used to be
while Riley Gaines has now announced her
support for Ron DeSantis for president
take a look
she is at the Forefront of the fight to
keep men out of women's sports former
Champion storm Riley Gaines and I am
officially endorsing Governor DeSantis
as president leadership has been crucial
in rooting out the radical ideology
that's really driving this insanity and
really bringing visibility to these
cultural issues that affect the
breakdown of families the breakdown of
Faith the breakdown of Freedom he's
really taken on this political
establishment the world corporations the
media and he's one and we know this
based off his success in Florida alone
Riley is a remarkable young woman has
had a great career and she's got a great
set of values that guide her life and
we're honored to have her support
you got to think about it this way does
she come off like a hater do you think
that Riley Gaines who spent most of her
youth like becoming the best freaking
swimmer she could possibly be do you
think she wanted anything to do with
politics do you think one day she wanted
to lose to a guy now again this is where
I have to mention Connor's theory on the
Leah Thomas situation because Leah
Thomas still has a penis and Conor's
theory has been we call this the Conor
Theory uh that Leah Thomas in these
swimming competitions is using the penis
as a propeller we don't know if that's
actually scientifically sound we're
looking into the uh you know what's
behind the scenes on that
um but you get it guys she did not want
any of this but she is going to now as a
public person and someone who has been
pushed into the fight courage begets
courage and now she's in on it he
defended her now she's defending him and
I think that's actually how you expand
uh truth and reality and everything else
speaking of Truth in reality we got one
more clip for you the great Douglas
Murray I don't know that we've played a
clip of Douglas Murray lately Douglas
Murray who's my friend Great British
conservative thinker actually lives in
New York right now I'm working on
getting him to Florida one thing at a
time uh he was on the Piers Morgan show
debating one of these uh far left woke
LGBT activists and you tell me does
anyone do it better than my good friend
Douglas Murray
I don't get this Sam Smith thing it just
seems like every week he deliberately
they why is one person there because
that's how they identity why have I got
to go along with it because they've
asked you to Sam Smith to me he's just
on an Ever deteriorating campaign to be
as vulgar and defensive as he possibly
can am I missing something he's doing
what pop stars have done for decades
which is trying to shock and the thing
that makes it different from other
people is that when Justin Timberlake or
Rihanna or someone stripped down they do
so because they look good like their
bodies look good Sam Smith is like pudgy
and very ugly you know what you're both
CIS white straight man you can carry on
I'm not assist anything first of all I
am white secondly I am a man thirdly
I've been out and gay my entire adult
life I was out as gay when you were
still prancing around talking about
whether or not you were it's a shame to
the queen you know what I tell you who's
really embarrassing myself
I got to call Douglas after this like I
I just love him because Douglas
he doesn't wear his sexuality on his
lapel or scream about it or have a
rainbow hat or anything else Douglas
tells you what he thinks about the world
he is one of the just great public
speakers and public thought leaders that
we have and that this kid see what this
kid thinks is that your sexuality is an
ideology right so he hears Douglas
Murray pushing back against Sam Smith or
pushing back against the broader lgbtqi
plus elementop two-spira thing and he
automatically thinks you must be
straight because he's assuming it's not
a sexuality it's a political ideology
and thus
is the problem so when they put that
flag up when Justin Trudeau takes down
the Canadian flag which he's now done
outside of the prime minister's office
in Canada and he puts up this flag what
he's putting up is a flag not to
celebrate oh you happen to be gay
Zippity damn Duda he's putting up a flag
that says oh you believe in equity you
believe in collectivism you believe that
the government should decide what you
learn and how you think and all of these
things so it's just an absolutely
beautiful moment and I'm going to buy
Douglas Maria pint next time I see him
we've got a post game show for you at
reubenreport.locals.com in about 26
seconds and my full episode with Jesse
Kelly who's just a great political
thinker and a fun dude is up right now
on locals I think part one's up across
platforms uh and we leave you with a
cold close Chris Christie announced he
was running for president yesterday I
guess we'll get to it at some point but
here was a little something and we'll
see everybody on the other side
and get a new crop of folks
come up here and talk to you
but I have to tell you
as I've watched the last year evolve
there's been just
one question
that kept going back and back and back
into my mind
and it was about our country and its
future
and I wondered
what our choice was going to be
we're going to be small
or are we going to be big
and let me tell you what I mean
[Music]